hey guys I'm Sally but you can call me
salamander if you want to you guys I'm
Ryan Ryan I like to make dick jokes
that's pretty accurate that's probably
the best impression someone's done of me
actually I might keep my voice down a
little bit if you notice where it's
Sally's today whenever I'm at Sally's I
have to talk a little quieter
cuz there's adults here who you know I
get scared of adults basically so today
we're gonna watch the first five minutes
of How to Train Your Dragon numero dos
yeah this films in Spanish and it's
gonna be very exciting but it's a
Spanish film yes it is you know that oh
it's a foreign film real quick before I
watch this you guys can't see this
Sally's in your shorts right now and she
like I've never like seen her in shorts
actually look at that good
I know what they look great though dude
you got it for you got a pretty good
body your butt looks great yeah
congratulations I hope you enjoyed that
that was me giving you all my gifts
because I was gone for a week Wow now I
gotta train my dragon to calm down you
know what okay let's watch the chairs
all right kids I hope you're watching
[Music]
[Music]
that's you when your boyfriend
dragon racing what a cool idea drag
racing oh yeah I get it
huh if it some goodies fat that's why
that's like a reading experience ragging
never she wants she gets
like a good dick job yeah the first one
just got ruined for yourself
so it's the minority but yeah exactly
it's a good anti-slavery message where's
the main character I can't believe this
is all based on a true story yeah it is
this really happened this is a
historical piece of woe
[Music]
see an adorable dragon so do you
I really pulled in I kind of just want
to watch the whole movie hmm
you still look pretty don't work when
you're about to fart sound like I've
heard of Spartacus doesn't was made an
announcement
and it's a so fun
oh man like no team he's a human dragon
[Applause]
you know people really do that stuff not
the flame with Dragons but the players
right doing horrible things of the
Dragon little Wang is five minutes ever
yeah I thought of the end in the clouds
it's an armed potatoes done cheap and
do-do-do-do Jewish voice of the guy yeah
he's a Jewish guy trust me I can do
anything
well the main character is Jewish and
they've never done that before
especially in a dragging movie you mean
like in the Dragon movie he says he's
Jewish she plays a Jew you haven't seen
the first one yet so yeah I know it
looks fun you know it looks like an
enjoyable family because there are some
movies that are just made for kids yeah
yeah how did train your dragon 2 and he
seems like you really got a handle on
training his dragon yeah man
chastity belts this you know what I mean
no I don't know well that's what it
feels like lately for this guy I really
wish you didn't wear shorts today Sally
now I know what I want to think about
tonight right before I go to bed what
that I'm on my period which is why my
lecture
and that's gonna anyway if you're new to
the channel you see this button now you
don't see it [ __ ] the matter with you
it's right there oh yeah I don't care
that you're on your period actually I
really appreciate you guys watching this
video what are you talking about Sally
it can't end yet you why shoutouts oh I
know you guys have to be nice because I
mean you guys are being very mean about
morning shoutouts hmm I started up
YouTube I never thought people on the
internet would be mean to me
yeah some of you guys better Chile I'm
fair okay I don't order I don't go and
pick a names out of a hat this isn't the
fight in Hunger Games okay I am very
considerate to make everyone equal ball
a ball sorry
above all sinister this guy he's been
making some interesting threats to me if
I don't give him a shout-out
he said he'll cut my dick off my dick my
dick my dick my dick my dick one time he
didn't break on it in a musical and I
did it's no weird it's like the tables
they have like in a way like they I know
there's a punch line to this so the turn
to this is how people come to the
channel for class a comedy who Sayed
Khan this dude's phone broke and he said
that it bummed him out because the only
thing he wanted to watch was the real
rejects and I was like dude Khan Khan
come come on you just touched my knee a
little that was no don't be sorry
right there thanks for bringing this up
Khan Dominic band Ola we actually were
going to give you a shout-out on the
transformers 4 TV spot we filmed that
one but then certain equipment pieces
like microphones off it would be a lie
if we were to refilm it it wouldn't be a
real reaction yeah exactly
people come here for the authenticity
they're organic you know when you do
trailer reactions long enough you
realize that it really is an art it's
about expression finding how you really
feel and
you know I made a comm drunk in the
Godzilla trailer people loved it
come on Sally come now you've made a
catchphrase for everyone all my boobs
for my channel oh yeah